حوادث تسميم الطالبات بالغاز تتوسع في
ايراننا
الشرطه الباكستانيه تفشل في القبض على
عمران خان
الامير هاري يدعو افراد اسرته لتلقي
العلاج النفسي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم القناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ثلاث 33 مدينه وبلده في سبعه عشره
محافظه توسعت فيها الهجمات بالمواد
الكيماويه ضد الفتيات في المدارس
الايرانيه منذ ثلاثه اشهر وحتى اليوم
سياسيون ونواب وناشطون ايرانيون اتهموا
جماعه متشدده ومتنفذه في النظام الايراني
بالوقوف خلف تلك الحوادث مؤكدين انها
متعمده وذات طابع امني وهدفها الانتقام من
انتفاضه المراه التي هزت اركان النظام
ولايه الفقيه خلال خمسه اشهر من
الاحتياجات العارمه
بناء على مذكره توقيف قضائيه دخلت الشرطه
الباكستانيه مقر اقامه رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان في مدينه لاهور شمال
شرقي البلاد لاعتقال في قضايا تتعلق
بالكسب غير المشروع وغسيل الاموال وغيرها
الشرطه فشلت في القاء القبض على خان حيث
لم يكن متواجدا في المكان فيما اظهرت
لقطات بثتها وسائل اعلام محليه رجال
الشرطه يقفون خارج المدخل الرئيسي لمنزل
خان ويمنعون دخول اي شخص اليك ويعتبر
عمران خان رئيس الوزراء الوحيد الذي اطيح
به بحجب الثقه في تاريخ باكستان السياسي
في احدث فصول الخلاف بين الطرفين كشف
الامير هاني انه شجع العائله المالكه في
بريطانيا على تلقي العلاج النفسي حتى
يتمكن من التحدث بلغته وفهمه بشكل افضل
على حد تعديره هاري اضاف في تصريحات جديده
انه يشعر دائما بانه مختلف عن بقيه افراد
عائلته وان والدته الراحل الاميره ديانا
كان لديها الشعور نفسه مؤكدا انهم استفاد
من التحدث الى المعالجين النفسيين ان
العلاج النفسي امر ضروري
خشيه من عمليه التجسس حضرت السلطات
العسكريه البريطانيه على افراد القوه
الجويه الخاصه استخدام تطبيق تيك توك
وغيره من منصات التواصل الاجتماعي على
هواتفهم الذكيه الخاصه بالعمل الخبراء
الامنيون في الجيش البريطاني يخشون ان
تؤدي التطبيقات التواصل الى تزويد دول مثل
الصين وروسيا ببيانات قد تساعد في تهديد
هويات افراد القوات الخاصه وايضا مواقعهم
السريه داخل المملكه المتحده وخارجها وحتى
تعريض العمليات التي ينفذونها للخطر
تحرك سريع اتخذته بعض الجامعات في
بريطانيا لحل المشكله الحديثه التي تسبب
بها تطبيق تشاد الذي اصبح الكثير من
الطلبه يلجاون اليه للغش في الامتحانات
صحيفه ديلي ميل ذكرت ان جامعات عده في
المملكه المتحده تبنت فكره اخضاع الطلبه
لفحص شفوي في حاله صارت شكوكو حول لجوئهم
الى الغش باستخدام تشات جي بي تي وفي حال
فشل الطالب في الاختبار يتم احالته الى
لجنه مخالفات اكاديميه تبث في امره وقد
تصل العقوبات الى حد الفصل من الجامعه